Simon Cowell MLB kiss and make up in
front of our cameras and todrick Hall is
only spilling to me secrets from Taylor
Swift's new video hello friends this is
the daily Deni and guess what it is our
50th show people oh you guys could do
better than that come on 50 yeah that's
right I am 50 years old and I want to
thank you for putting up with my absurd
obsession with celebrity news and gossip
and if you're joining us for the first
time welcome the world is a little
gnarly right now so I do hope we bring
you some light fun and entertainment and
on that note I was back at America's Got
Talent last night and after last week's
tenth night between Simon and Mel be the
spicy girl nearly got to exact her
revenge now I would love you please to
plunge that knife into Simon Cowell's
chest
ask you though after last week how
nervous and out tents were you up there
knowing that she had that knife in her
hand
Oh what do you think you know I'm
looking at these knives think you know
they all look to me like real knives and
she actually wants to kill me I could
see it in her eyes
you're a nightmare by the way all right
no no no no no you know we've done it
we've done it we've done it way to go
good girl what's it like picking on the
boss he's not my boss I'm the boss of me
just another night of love and war at
AGT but the moment of the night belonged
to kechi a plane crash survivor who also
happens to be from Houston her
performance last night an inspiring
moment of hope
and decided to stay wasn't what a little
of take me out
the lyrics you know I resonate with them
so personally that you know sometimes
during the song I would have to catch
myself not to you know get overwhelmed
by my feelings that's the first for me
to ever finish singing and start crying
that that's never happened that's the
first time I've ever really connected
truly with a song so that's also a big
moment you know it's a very huge moment
you to feel cathartic do you feel
relieved yes I felt like I was like all
these emotions yeah that's how I felt
obviously your hometown is suffering
right now how did how are you able to
get through this with knowing your
hometown I imagine is weighing heavily
on your heart and mind it's scary
first of all cuz you don't even know you
know when you wake up if it's still
gonna be raining is how many more people
are gonna be affected but I feel like a
lot of people are rising to the occasion
to like help people you know there's a
lot of like you know helping hand you
know people that aren't affected or
trying to help busy we're affected and
it's just been so positive the way
people are responding what do you hope
people take away from your story hope I
want people to know that no matter how
much life tries to push you down I want
people to know that you can not only
rise above you can not only get back on
your feet but you can thrive
a truly beautiful moment you know catchy
told me backstage that the world needs
to see that kind of strength and others
and I couldn't have said it any better
myself
we'll find out if she makes it through
to the semi-final tonight on NBC but
moving on to my Facebook live chat with
todrick Hall he is featured in Taylor
Swift's music video for look what you
made me do and just when we thought we
couldn't possibly learn any more about
this video
todrick shares just what went into
Taylor turning out that unexpected dance
break
[Music]
like not with myself and I just want you
to know that is the first and only time
you're ever gonna see me in a crop top
so screen shot that making your Springs
everyone ever happening again I had no
idea that's what I was gonna be wearing
I was super into it but I was very very
nervous I've never done anything like
that before in my entire life so what
was your reaction when you realize not
only would you be wearing a crop top but
it said I heart TS we've seen that we've
seen those pictures we've seen yeah
what'd you think I just thought it was
brilliant she's just such an iconic and
epic person and whatever she'd whatever
she puts her hands on always turns to
gold and I love the fact that she
expresses how she feels through her
music as opposed to on Twitter on social
media it's always done in such an epic
and creative way this is the first time
we've seen Taylor do some serious
choreography like this absolutely she
brought it I mean how impressed were you
by her I was so impressed because no
shade two other people in the industry
but there are a lot of people who try to
dance but with her it seems very natural
we've had a lot of experience Taylor and
I dancing at the club so I knew that she
had what it took but sometimes it's
difficult to translate you're from your
club dancing yeah to your on-camera
dancing and I thought she did such an
amazing job at it she was like so like
kick-ass and we didn't film it that many
times she just killed it every single
performance how many takes was that not
a lot I mean they obviously did a lot of
camera moves but she she she just nailed
it every time we didn't have to go back
because she was messing up choreography
she was it was just a very I mean I've
worked with Beyonce and I've gotten to
work with Taylor and it was a very
similar thing she's a perfectionist
she was never gonna go out on camera and
not show herself in the best light and I
thought she was amazing for your first
time ever dancing that looks like she's
been dancing her entire life how much
did you know about the video and the
concept before signing on I didn't know
very much about it and I understood why
she wasn't able to tell me a lot because
it was a huge project and so close to
her and she filmed it so much before it
came out so I respected that and
completely was like I trust that you're
gonna put me in a positive light and
that the video is going to be amazing I
would have never dreamed that it was
gonna be breaking all of these records
so quickly know if I'm supposed to say
this or not but on the day that it came
out she sent everybody this beautiful
bouquet of flowers and said you know
thank you so much for being a part of it
keeping it a secret because it just made
it so much more epic by the way you
didn't think I was gonna let him leave
without teaching me some of that choreo
did you can I see the brake can I see a
little bit of the dance break thank you
thank you very much I'm a quick learner
before you start commenting I will keep
my day job don't worry all right
and finally you guys know my favorite
celebrity couple by which I measure
every relationship in Hollywood is John
Legend and Chrissy Teigen well let me
tell you they just keep getting sweeter
one week after Chris he revealed the
cosmos she is cutting back on alcohol
after admitting she was drinking too
much
her hubby tells the magazine how much he
supports her decision quote when she was
thinking about how she wanted to drink
less we talked about it he adds I want
her to be happy and to live the fullest
most awesome life she can now these two
have always been open with et about
their plants to make Luna a big sister
even though they struggle with fertility
John also tells the magazine quote IVF
brought us Luna and hopefully it will
bring us a few more awesome kids too
I don't know about you but I wouldn't
mind some more Legend Tegan offspring
and I also wouldn't mind you guys coming
back for more daily Denny I got to give
a quick special shout out to my ragtag
team behind the scenes who helped get
this show done every single day and
again thank you for hanging out with us
on the daily - be sure to LIKE comment
and share and I promise I will deliver
the goods you know the deal it's time to
dance our way out of here thank you guys
so much for watching yo yeah